heads of state from the Sahel arrived in
Wagga dugu there is a security crisis in
the region following an insurgency by
armed groups allied to al-qaeda in the
Islamic State of Iraq and the Levant
fighters have carried out a series of
attacks in Burkina Faso Mauritania Mali
Chad and Nazaire there's concern that
this problem could spread beyond the
Sahel and to other coastal countries we
have said that there needs to be a link
between development and security if we
develop the affected areas there will be
security and if we provide good security
we can develop those areas this summit
has been organized by West Africa's
regional bloc ECOWAS and has brought
together presidents from the Sahel
countries called g5 mandated to fight
terrorism and illegal migration across
borders representatives from other West
African countries affected by extremist
groups like the Boko Haram are also here
burkina faso has seen increased attacks
in recent years until a few years ago
when burkina faso's former president
lays compared it was removed from power
in a popular uprising the country was
largely safe but in 2016 on this street
in the capital was a googol armed men
stormed into that hotel and two
restaurants more than 20 people were
killed that monument is a reminder of
what happened here the attacks have
spread to the east and north of the
country about 500 people have been
killed and nearly 300,000 displaced like
bonobo bimla who's hosted by
well-wishers in a town about a hundred
kilometers away from where the leaders
are meeting she fled from her home
farther north two months ago the other
thing they came to our village and began
shooting everywhere we fled with our
children we walked for over 15
kilometres we came here with nothing the
leaders in Wagga dugu say the only way
to help millions of people like Bill
Maher and her children is by working
together implementing what will be
decided
at the summit though will be the harder
parts Catherine soil al-jazeera Wagga
dugu bikina fossil